[MUSIC PLAYING]
CY KHORMAEE: My name is
Cy, I'm a product manager
with Google Cloud.
And with that,
let's get into it.
So I think hopefully
most of folks in the room
are security or
security adjacent
have some experience with the
problems of protecting users.
You knoqm users are under
attack from phishing, malware,
and fraud at all times.
And it's really unique compared
to protecting our own employees
because we have less
control over the environment
in which our users exist.
But they're just as
important to our business.
You know, with
phishing, you know,
91% of all targeted attacks
start with phishing.
That's one huge vector in
not only to your own systems,
but to your customers
and your users.
And 8% of revenue for
many online businesses
is lost to fraud every year.
The problem is just the
defense of these systems,
especially you go all the way
out to the users' computers,
requires a lot of
data and the ability
to protect at the client
level in an environment
that you don't control.
Now, just for some background,
you know, here at Google,
we've been protecting
our own systems
with two spectacular
platforms for the last decade,
and maybe even
more in some cases.
The first is Safe
Browsing, which
defends over three
billion devices
from phishing and malware.
And then the other
is reCAPTCHA, which
defends more than
two million websites
from fraudulently using bots.
And we really took
these two platforms
and leveraged them to create
offerings that you all can now
use in order to protect your
own platforms users and devices.
The first of these products
is reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
Now, reCAPTCHA
Enterprise is essentially
an extension of reCAPTCHA
V3 into the enterprise space
to allow for more nuance
and granular control
and smarter and more
refined decision
making around what to
do with fraud that you
observe on your site.
The second two are based
off of Safe Browsing.
The first one there will
be phishing protection,
which essentially leverages
the power of Safe Browsing
to discover phishing sites that
are targeting your company.
To add those, help you get
those added to Safe Browsing
as well as enable you
to potentially submit
your own URLs you observed
to be attacking your users
to save browsing.
And then the third product
we'll introduce is Web Risk.
And Web Risk is a
URL, again, built
on the power of
Safe Browsing that
enables you to check URLs
in your own infrastructure
on your own site in the content
that you serve for unsafe URLs.
And with that, we'll do a
little bit of a deep dive
in each one of these here.
We'll start out here with
reCAPTCHA Enterprise,
and really wanted
to kind of frame
the problem of how we see a lot
of what we think of reCAPTCHA
is just defending against
bots, which it does,
but it also defends against all
different manner of attacks.
And this could be scraping
fraudulent transactions,
account takeovers, synthetic
accounts, false posts, money
laundering, and many, many more.
I'm never cease to be amazed by
the creativity and innovation
of our adversaries.
So there are just
this myriad of threats
that try and abuse your sites.
And really the goal
with the reCAPTCHA,
and reCAPTCHA
enterprise, specifically,
is to make it as
hard as possible
for these adversaries to
access anything on your site,
be it the login page
or even your home page,
and make it as easy as possible,
and in fact, as frictionless
as possible for your own users
to engage with and conduct
legitimate business
on your site.
Now how are we able to do that?
You know, reCAPTCHA really
has an unprecedented level
of visibility of abuse across
the web from the two million
sites that we work with.
And we're able to kind of
combine all these collective,
collaborative defenses to
create a unique view on what
legitimate and what
illegitimate transactions look
like across this large
population, which it enables us
to train machine
learning models that
are able to recognize attacks in
their many and evolving forms.
And speaking of evolving,
I want to walk you
through a quick history of
our reCAPTCHA to bring you up
to speed because
I think people's
understanding of this platform
vary because it's just been
around for so long and
has been experienced
by so many different
people in different ways.
Really, it got started with
the squiggly bit of text
that you're trying
to read and type in.
And as bots got better,
our defenses had to evolve.
And that's why you see these
click boxes and crosswalks
where the challenges have become
a little bit more complex.
And I know many people in the
audience, myself included--
can't touch the mic--
have trouble solving.
And the reason they've
gotten so complicated
is not only just
because of the AI threat
but also because of
the farmer threat.
So there are large groups
of, even warehouses full,
of people who are
solving these challenges.
So the threat is in fact a human
threat as well as a bot threat.
And we really have
to distinguish
legitimate from
fraudulent transactions
not just bots from
humans anymore.
Not to mention that AI
get smarter every day,
and maybe those will converge
with the human threat.
And so really that brought
us to this, which you know
is nothing.
Just kidding.
So really what it is a
piece of JavaScript that
can live almost anywhere on
your site, anywhere on the web,
interact with the
user, and give you
essentially a risk
or a confidence
score in whether
this interaction's
fraudulent or not, without
interrupting your user,
and without being easily tested
or defeated by a piece of AI
or a bot written
by an adversary.
And really this is
our effort to go
into the behavioral
analytic space
and really try and use not just
the challenge but, in fact,
everything you can
observe about the user
from their interaction
on the client
in order to make
a determination.
Again, that's not only
better for users in that it
causes zero user friction.
In fact, most users
aren't even aware
that they are passing this test.
But it also is much harder to
defeat because the adversaries
don't have a strong idea of what
they have to program against
or a way to train
their own attacks.
And now with the reCAPTCHA
enterprise, what we found
is that with the
introduction of E3,
you can put the
snippet anywhere,
which means that you have a
much broader set of use cases
around where you can use this.
I think in V2, a lot of
the common use cases we saw
was around the login flow.
When there's already going
to be a user interaction
and already interrupt
there, we can
add a little bit of extra
friction keep it secure.
Now with a frictionless
experience,
you can put it
anywhere on your site,
kind of just like
Google Analytics would.
And because of that,
there's many more use cases
that we want to enable
enterprises, you all,
to attune your business to and
to attune your fraud and risk
teams to.
And so we added higher
granularity risk scores.
So rather than four
scores, you get
10 reason codes that'll
tell you why we thought
something on your site was high
risk or something on your site
might be worth looking at.
And then an
annotation API, which
is a means by which you
can help us tune our model
and tune our protection
to your particular site
and your particular use case.
So we can get higher accuracy
and higher granularity
on our defenses for your own
site and your own business.
So just with a higher
granularity use
score, kind of one
example of one way
to think about it is if you
have very low granularity,
you can do defenses of
very different use cases.
For example,
defending a login page
versus defending a home page.
If you defend a
home page, maybe you
allow some questionable
transactions through,
or maybe you don't care
at all if you don't
care if bots scrape your site.
Many retailers we work
with, that's the case.
Whereas very few
people want anyone
scraping or having automated
uses of their login page.
That's generally a bad thing.
Now, that would be good
if you have this the four
buckets and that as that--
what that was designed for.
With higher granularity,
with these 10 buckets,
you can draw even
finer controls.
For example, the way you treat
threats against a password
reset form versus a login form.
Maybe those two are different
vectors and different levels
of security.
And you can start making these
really fine-tune controls
and tuning that true positive,
false positive, false negative
rate for every specific
part of your business.
So you can ensure that you
maximize the friction again
for those attackers
and you minimize it
for your users or legitimate
folks trying to use your site.
Along that same lines,
we have our reason codes.
And here are just a few.
And again, going back to
maybe the scraping example
with automation.
If we identify something
as an automation attack,
maybe it doesn't matter
if it's on your home page.
Maybe you don't
care if folks are
scraping the basic
information you'd
like the whole world to know.
But rarely would you want
to see that on a login page
or potentially, like,
a sending message
page or various other avenues
for abuse within your site.
And then the other two
patterns are just ways for you
to potentially identify
different behaviors
that you wouldn't want
to see on your site.
So, for example, the
unexpected environment
indicates that their reCAPTCHA
snippet has been extracted.
And that's a common way
that these reCAPTCHA farmers
will extract the
reCAPTCHA snippet
into a different environment
and have it solved externally.
Typically not a good thing,
not being used as intended.
As well as the unexpected
usage patterns, which
could be any wide variety of
things, where you say, hey,
this doesn't match the
typical legitimate behavior
we see for users on
your site on this page.
Again, we make it
really, really hard,
where the adversaries to
defeat this are starting
to have to map to not
only typical users, not
only to your site,
but specifically
to the behavior that would
be expected on your site
on your page, which makes it
a much, much tougher defense
and also much easier
on your users.
And then the last piece
here is the annotation
or the annotate API call.
So when you use
reCAPTCHA, it'll send
you back a score and a label.
So again, that score.
There's 10 scores as
well as the labels
that we showed before as
well as-- and then when
you receive those, you
can annotate them and send
them back to further
help train this model.
Something we heard
continuously is that we really
would like to share
ground truth with Google
and really help use the
ground truth that you see
in your business to help
us create a model that's
particular and tailored to your
business and to your company.
And this will enable
us to do that.
And here's how it works.
It looks quite simple,
but basically you
just take the assessment that
you're given back from Google.
As you think about
implementing this,
be sure to save that number.
It's like your kind of receipt.
And then use that
to send us back
a note that says, well, this
was a legitimate or fraudulent
transaction.
And you can do both.
And you can do it for
whether we're right
or whether we're wrong.
All will help us train
and label our data sets
to get better attuned
to your specific sites.
Rather than, again, being
served by this general model
of the entire web, we can start
using all of our protections
and knowledge to tailor a
model specific to your site.
And just a little bit for folks
who may already be V3 users.
I actually can't see, but how
many people in the audience
are V3 users already?
That's pretty good.
I see four or five hands go up.
By the way, this is the
product team in the front row.
All the head snapped
round of intense interest.
So the folks who are in V3
or any version of reCAPTCHA,
really the only change you
have to make is-- let's see,
this thing doesn't
laser point, does it?
Anyways, at the top
end screen here, you
can see the end user client
and the reCAPTCHA endpoint
will kind of have a
little conversation.
A token be generated and sent
back to the reCAPTCHA customer
server.
From the recapture
customer server,
where typically your
server code will live,
typically you'd send that to
the reCAPTCHA assessment call
to be decoded.
Instead you'll send it to a GCP
reCAPTCHA enterprise end point.
It's basically like one
line of code change.
And essentially it'll work
in more or less same way,
except you get more data back.
So just a note, if you're
transitioning from V3
to reCAPTCHA, it's about
a one line of code change.
Should be very, very
straightforward.
And we designed it to
work in a very similar way
to V3, so to make that
transition seamless.
And also here's kind of
what the assessment will
look like when you get it back.
Again, you can see the
confidence highlighted
there is going to be 0.1.
So that's kind of the
score we discussed.
And it runs from 0 to 1
in decimal increments.
And then you'll also get
reasons, if they exist.
It could be blank.
But if not, we'll
give you the reasons,
for example, automation
that you might expect.
And so I know it's
early in the morning.
And I know it's
dark in the theater,
so if anyone's dozed off,
now is the time to wake up.
We'll do a little live
demo, which is always
the most exciting thing
to do as a presenter,
especially if a security
product, by the way.
So let's all do it together.
Do me a favor, go to
g.co/recaptcha/demo.
And I'll leave that up
for a couple more seconds.
And if we can, can we
switch over to my laptop.
There you go.
And hopefully you all
will see a screen that
looks a little bit like this.
Now, this is just kind
of a test demo page
of what a user experience
could look like with reCAPTCHA
and what the admin
experience looks like.
Let me say, please do not
put it in a real password
or username here.
This is just a test.
So we don't want any
actual data in all.
You know, you can put
in whatever you want.
And log in.
And you'll see the--
let's see, let me ignore this.
You'll see a little
thank you screen.
I know Chrome wants
to save your password.
Word of advice, use
password managers.
They're great, except in demos.
So if you see here, kind of
standard, frictionless user
experience.
You wouldn't even know
you're using reCAPTCHA.
And by the way, if you're
curious, on your devices,
you can go to this page
and sign up right now.
So we got a little sign up link.
But as an admin here,
you can actually
see that actually a lot
of people, that's great.
So thanks for the
early engagement.
Looks like about 18 or so people
tried to access this page,
and everyone got through.
A lot legitimate traffic.
No bots in the audience, as far
as I can tell, which is good.
However, if I try and run
it with a bot, and again,
the team here helped me out to
write a headless browser that
will go and attack
the page, much
like many of the
bots that attack
your pages in the
wild will, and then it
will return a screenshot
of what it sees.
And we'll see that it has a,
hopefully if it runs here--
we're always on the
Wi-Fi, which is like a--
it's never a sure thing.
But it'll basically run.
And then hopefully when
the output is finished,
it will show a screenshot
of what it sees.
There we go.
And you can see
here, it's seeing
a 2FA challenge rather
than the Thank You page
that you all saw.
And as you can imagine,
in your own sites
and your own
businesses, that you'd
want essentially
those users to have
that frictionless
experience that you all saw
and have bots like this that
are running these repeated
automated attacks
seeing it to 2FA screen,
so they can't really test
passwords against your page.
And as we go back
to the analytics,
you can see as an admin
these attacks happening.
You can see that they're marked
as illegitimate transactions.
And you can see that the
reason code is automation.
So you can start to track
these attacks as they happen,
and then again, start to tune
and playing your defenses
around that.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
That's the end of the
demo, so thank you
all for participating.
I appreciate it.
Early in the morning, it's
good to see that enthusiasm
for great security products.
And so that's about it.
Really our goal with
reCAPTCHA enterprise
is to stop fraud, not users.
You can learn more at
cloud.google.com/recaptcha
enterprise.
I will note for those you can
see typing this in already--
this will all go live at
9:00 AM tomorrow morning.
So all this stuff is
technically pre-launch.
You are getting the
sneak peek, what
is it, about 22 hours
before everyone else does.
So take a note and then
it'll be live in about a day.
The next product that I wanted
to dive a little bit deeper
into was phishing protection.
And just to outline this--
the way I like to
think about phishing,
it's something our team has
worked for more than a decade
on, is it doesn't matter what
kind of big huge, scary castle
you build, you
leave the gate open,
everyone's going to come in.
And that really is the
case with phishing.
We build some pretty
amazing defenses.
We see everyone across industry
build amazing defenses.
I think everyone in
the room probably
knows that phishing is still
your number one problem.
It's people leaving
the door unlocked.
Really the goal with
phishing protection
is to stop people from
clicking on phishing, period.
Right we know that
with enough tries,
and essentially
the tries are free,
people will always be fooled
into clicking at some level.
So we really want to ensure
that as few people see
those links as possible, and
especially for those links
that are targeting your brands.
So, for example,
some of them might
use say, the Google
logo, or the Gmail logo,
or things that are
used in our iconography
for pages to denote their log in
pages offerings to fool users,
especially using,
say, mobile devices.
And phishing protection
leverages the power
of Safe Browsing to not
only classify those pages
but also to add them to
the Safe Browsing list
when they match our
policy, in order
to ensure that users will
see a big red warning that
looks a little bit
like this color
before they ever go to a
phishing and a malware page.
So they're very aware.
And typically they
don't go there.
I think our click-through
rate is well below 3%.
So in the few places
in our business
where we focus on
having the lowest
click-through rate possible.
Just to walk through a
little bit of how this works.
You as a business can submit
URLs to phishing production.
So, oftentimes, there's existing
detections from referral links,
from your own email
and security tools,
or just from your own
scraping of the web.
Usually there's some
really smart IT person,
someone who's written a cool
bot to find things that look
like your brand on the web.
You can submit those to
Safe Browsing for crawling,
so we can confirm that they
are truly indeed malicious.
We have a team of
about 60 engineers
who spent the better
part of a decade building
machine learning to
recognize these things
and recognize them
as they evolve.
So we have incredibly good
detections around those.
We also ingest
data from a variety
of third party sources or
even first party sources
from within Google.
Once those are all
added to Safe Browsing,
we'll notify you as
a customer, so you
can institute your
own countermeasures,
be it take downs, blocks,
notifications, user education,
whatever it is you've found
work well for your customers
and your business.
You'll get that protection on
three billion plus devices.
I'll note, this is far
beyond the reach of Chrome
or any Google products.
The vast majority of
browsers, security companies,
web-filtering companies
use this list in order
to protect their users.
So you get a wide variety
of protections almost
wherever your users are.
And then finally, this will
be integrated into the GCP
reporting analytics through
Cloud Security Command Center.
Quick note just for
at a technical level.
This is what submitted
URL looks like.
It's very simple.
You use your project number
and API key to submit a URI.
And then we take
it in, and you'll
see it come out the other end in
Cloud Security Command Center.
And if we can switch
over to my laptop,
we'll show the
quick demo what that
looks like from the Cloud
Security Command Center vantage
point.
Here's kind of the
dashboard you'll
see as an admin of Cloud
Security Command Center, which
is kind of your one
single pane of glass
to see all the
different security
activities within your business.
It's a great way
here at GCP we're
trying to consolidate all
of the many dashboards.
I know we all love
to flip through doing
our daily business.
You can see here
the finding summary.
You see about 177 findings.
And when you click
on that, you'll
see a full list of the different
findings that are available.
And as you click in, you can see
the full details we'll offer,
so you can see the
data was discovered.
You can see, at the bottom
there, under source properties,
was it flagged by Safe Browsing?
Did it-- was it reported by
the organization, essentially
was it reported to us?
And what was the URL.
And oftentimes folks will look
for that combination of flagged
by Safe Browsing
and reported by you
because obviously the
ones you care most about
are the ones you found,
you want re-mediated,
and you want to know
what we did about it.
So we'll provide that, and
we'll also be providing support
from the product team.
You have escalations
or questions
around why something
was classified,
we can offer that back.
I know for some
folks, Safe Browsing
and our phishing
products have been
a little bit of a black box.
So we're hoping to enjoy a
little tighter partnership
with our enterprise customers
through this product.
All right, and that was it.
So we'll switch
back to the slides.
Last time, I promise.
Thank you to the
guys in the booth.
And here you can
just learn more here
at cloud.google.com/phishing
protection.
And it's a way to help you
find and prevent phishing
before users click.
And the last product we'll
talk about today is web risk.
And web risk is
essentially a way
to protect you from
malicious URLs.
We all know that URLs can
contain dangerous stuff.
You know, phishing, malware,
all sorts of bad stuff.
And Safe Browsing examines more
than a billion URLs every day
in order to create a list
of a million or more URLs.
And really, it's access to that
list that we're providing now.
And here's an example of maybe
how can work in practice.
So let's say there's
a rub site, Acme Tech
Reviews for tech events
in San Francisco,
like Google Cloud Next.
And it gets more popular.
But as it gets more
popular, you see a bunch
of this malware come up.
And this is actually a very
common trending behavior
we see.
As sites, as businesses
hit this inflection point,
where they attract users who
are becoming really popular,
we see the fraud come
right along with it.
So rides right on the coattails
of your success, which
is often quite frustrating.
And then it kind of dampens it.
So as that site
gets more popular,
attracts more malicious
content that showing up
on the site, it starts
to drive users away,
which is bad for that business
and bad for that business's
growth.
And so really with the Web Risk
API, what this business, Acme
Tech Reviews, could do is
send good and bad URLs,
all URLs posted to its
site, to the Web Risk API
to check to see if they're
known to be malicious
or known to be unsafe or not.
With the Web Risk API
will send the data
on known unsafe or known bad
URLs back to the Acme Tech
Reviews site.
And then Acme Tech
Reviews can only
post the URLs that
were not found
to be bad to the
actual public site,
and that way make
sure its content is
a lot safer and more secure.
And then its users aren't being
targeted by the propagation
of malicious content.
And here's really quickly what
the queries will look like.
There's two basic methods.
One is you can
essentially submit a URL,
and that's the one on your left.
And submit a URL, get a
verdict back, pretty simple.
The other one
essentially consists
of a local database
of partial hashes
you can run queries against.
And when there's a query
match, we'll send back.
And you can see
that on the right,
you can see a list of
different URLs and they match.
This is not only
faster, but it's also
privacy preserving because
Google never actually sees
the URL you were looking for.
We only see a set of possible
URLs you might be looking for,
you might be interested in.
As you know here, expire time
will kind of denote the time
for which we would like we--
our terms encourage you
consider the URLs unsafe.
And the negative
expire time is the time
which we discourage you
from making another call
because it's unlikely
the verdict will change,
even if there is no verdict.
So kind of consider
it like, you know,
don't ask again
for a little bit.
I'm going to go
back to our example.
So now let's say Acme
Reviews has installed
this, and it's starting
to filter their sites.
What will happen
is they'll start
to make sure that their site
is free of malicious content
and the users return and
their growth can continue.
So for any company that
does content filtering, has
large amounts of
user-generated content,
highly encourage them to take
a look at this Web Risk API.
We actually launched
this back at RSA,
so this is the one
product that's up.
You can go look on it now at
cloud.google.com/web-risk.
And again, we have data on
more than a million URLs
from scanning billions a day.
And I wanted to just
close quickly here
with a discussion of how this
fits together as a hijacking
prevention use case.
So fraud, and just
attacks in general,
things that are self
propagating and work together.
Someone phishes a user,
steals a password,
tries it on a website through
automated credential stuffing,
or even manual
credential stuffing,
and then it's-- that compromised
site is used to re-post more
phishing and more malware.
And that negative,
malicious cycle continues.
We really designed this
suite to work together
to block every
step of that cycle.
So phishing
protection's designed
to stop users from
clicking on phishing
to ensure that they are--
the passwords aren't stolen
the first place.
We have reCAPTCHA enterprise,
and among many other things,
will stop credential stuffing,
and stop those passwords
from being used, even
if they are compromised
or, at very least,
giving you some
notice that people are
using these in an attack.
And then finally, we
have Web Risk, which
prevents the propagation
of phishing and malware
through these large
user-content sites
and through any sort of
security filtering systems,
be it email or anything
else, to ensure
that even if the
site is compromised,
it doesn't start spreading
to the rest of our ecosystem.
[MUSIC PLAYING]